you were called a false prophet because
you had tattoos right uh you know some
people see my inverted pentagram and
they're like why is that guy got a
pentagram he's some kind of satanist
insider
in today's culture tattoos are getting
more and more popular but what does the
bible actually say about tattoos find
out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
what's up everybody welcome back to led
live today we got a special show because
we got a special guest this is tiller
from school for prophets and we're going
to be talking about what the bible has
to say about tattoos because me and till
actually have tattoos and we work in
ministry and we get a lot of
fun comments about
you were called a false prophet because
you had tattoos right yeah
you know some people see my inverted
pentagram and they're like why is that
guy got a pentagram he's some kind of
satanist insider but we're going to talk
about what the bible actually has to say
about tattoos and that you can actually
get tattoos before you become a
christian and they don't just go away so
that's kind of uh our testimony about
what why we have tattoos so you actually
did at least two videos maybe three
videos on this subject yeah two or three
videos on that because it was getting
brought up a lot about your tattoos yeah
yeah a lot of people were calling me out
on it and saying that i wasn't a real
christian because
of the tattoos not knowing that i did
have a past you know what i mean right
so what do you think about
that i mean christians having tattoos i
mean before we get into that i just want
to address that just a tiny little bit
um with people uh you know so we're so
quick to judge and and throw things out
and call people out on the carpet and
this and that
um you know i can remember the very
first time i ever preached a sermon i
was wearing a wedding ring and people
just i mean hammered me like how dare
you wear a wedding ring and this and
that you know and then it's like you
know notice like now i don't i don't
feel like i need to wear a wedding ring
my marriage is on my heart and i and i
and i have changed as i've gone along
and not to say that you know just
wearing a ring is wrong but the person
that called me out on it they could have
easily just just said hey have you ever
seen any information on you know maybe
jewelry and this and that and now here
let me send you something like that
would be a better approach than to just
straight up call you a false prophet you
know what i mean like to call you up in
love and say hey tilla like i've got
some information on this i'd like to
share it with you would you be open to
looking at it that's the way we should
respond
right and also just you know talking to
me personally as well you know i mean
like
just having a conversation with me maybe
i had you know something happened to me
in the past and now i'm different you
know what i mean yeah and so
a conversation would be like a direct
email instead of a comment yeah
unsubscribe yeah yeah yeah you got
tattoos but i think we should i think we
should respond to those kind of
situations like like we i imagine jesus
would you know he didn't show up with
the woman at the well and just start
like blasting her you know he he was
gentle in his approach and it was enough
to convict her of that so i think if we
see somebody doing something wrong or
that we disagree with i don't mind
people you know giving me criticism or
coming at it but we need to do it in
love and there's a proper way to do it
and we can bring up those topics in a
gentle way you know amen yeah and like
you said the the approach was wrong but
you were wearing a ring that's not
something that's like permanent that was
a long time ago so that was kind of like
a current thing but there's a lot of
we were just talking about this before
the show there's a lot of situations
where
something is permanently now in your
life such as keith an example of
you know you have a child out of wedlock
and now you're in ministry
are people going to be like you can't be
a pastor you had that kid
10 years ago out of wedlock
what about repentance what about
forgiveness you know what about
uh being a renewed creature having a
renewed mind and and starting on a new
path that's what it's all about you know
it's a rebirth being born again and you
start a new path
so what what inspired you to get tattoos
um
in the culture that i was in i was a
battle rapper you know before i became a
christian so we got the microphone yes
yeah you got the microphone yeah and uh
so in that culture i was in the hip hop
culture
and you know getting tattoos was normal
you know it's just something that that
you you you like to show off yourself
it's
to me it's kind of
it makes you proud yeah i mean it makes
you proud
you show off your artwork or whatever
that represents you
it might be kind of a an intimidating
thing as well you look at some of these
like tribal people where they paint
their face and you know war paint it's
to to
kind of look tougher than the other guy
and if you're a battle rapper you know
maybe you're just scrawny and don't got
muscles or whatever get some tats now
you look a little tough you know
piercing or something i think it was you
that was showing me a video one time of
of somebody that said he had all these
tattoos on his face and he said that he
did that because if you were gonna
approach him and have a conversation
with him you really wanted to talk to
him and it was a way to push people away
from coming to him and and i thought
that was a really interesting concept
that you know you had this persona you
had to appear
and it filtered all the people that you
know were kind of fake or whatever and
if you really were going to push past
that that's who they were looking for
deep down inside i think we're all
wanting acceptance right yeah
yeah that was london lee he said it
the guy had tattoos everywhere yeah
to keep fake people away that's right
i mean i don't justify tattoos with that
but it's kind of an interesting
uh concept you know because if you're
willing to talk to me when i look like
this you know that's that's one bad
thing too is we judge so much on
appearance we've talked about this on
other shows like
if you're attractive you get talked to
more
i mean
for instance say
an ugly overweight balding man walks by
a beautiful woman and says hey yeah you
doing she might be like who are you yeah
but if it's an attractive man like hey
how you doing oh hey you know
it's just like we're
we're engaging in conversation because
of your appearance i mean it's very
superficial
and i hate that that's even a concept
but it really is it's like what they
call the halo effect and the
horns effect right
yeah yeah we did a whole show on that so
and like beautiful people are even
looked at as more trustworthy more um
sociable
friendly all these things that really
aren't true when you look at like some
of the most beautiful people in
hollywood who probably wouldn't even
give you a second
thought you know or respond to you so
how influenced were you guys both on
maybe your peers or people you say
you're involved in the rap
you know a battle game um a lot of
people i'm assuming had tattoos back
then did you feel that you needed to
kind of get them to feel like you fit
into that crowd
yeah yeah that's that's part of it um
for the most part like
me personally i just wanted to show off
the artwork you know i just wanted to
show off myself and
also yeah to fit in as well to fit in so
was it your artwork
um
some of it like this this right here
this is my artwork
yeah but i had a i had a help you know
with a friend
um and then you know just to show off my
who i am you know like this and this is
my my um my daughter's name
and my my language
and um so this is pretty much for me for
the most part just to just to show off
and just to to look cool
you know
yeah i have a old books of all these
different printed out things that i'd
plan on getting tattoos for and i look
back i'm like dude i'm so glad i didn't
get a lot of those tattoos actually
there was an experience when
i was going to visit my mom she lived
five hours away from me and and i had
like an hour or two hours or something
before i needed to get on the road and i
went into the tattoo shop with a
pentagram and i was gonna get right on
the top of my hand
and i went in there and i said hey how
much for this and he looked at it he
goes what is that a pentagram or
something i don't do pentagrams and i
was like
what i was like you don't do money or
what like
no i didn't question because he was just
so like authoritative about it like i
don't do pentagrams i was just like
i walked out i was so confused i was
like mad because i'm like i wanted to
get this i got the money for it you're
turning me down like who doesn't tattoo
whatever you want for money but
i look back now i'm like dude maybe god
put that in his mind like you don't feel
like doing a pentagram today or
something yeah
you know it is interesting like what you
what you want
tattooed on your body the only tattoo i
was actually aiming at getting when i
was in my early 20s was a dragon
i think about that now and it's like why
did i want a dragon on me the reason i
wanted a pentagram what was it what was
that all about and you know why why are
tattoos traditionally dark oh yeah
that's a good point so like on the
on the screen here we have some
religious art and i loved religious art
even before i was a christian
i collected
buddha statues and
jesus crucifixions and stuff like that
and i actually had plans to make
this sleeve all religious art and this
was going to be more
dark yeah
it was going to be like a dualistic type
thing and before i even knew what that
was you know but
yeah traditionally or
most of the time the majority of the
time when you go into a tattoo shop
you don't see
pretty wholesome things you see skulls
snakes
weapons it's not like hearts and
kindness and you know it's usually like
yeah
cross me and i'll kill you you know like
kind of stuff maybe the girls get that
stuff but that's not what all the flash
you know these big posters that you flip
with the flash art on there
i think maybe
maybe
statistically guys probably get more
tattoos than girls girls get them but
guys are like yes leave out my whole
body and it is it's all a bunch of dark
stuff
so so what does the bible say about it
do you guys know i mean like have you
have you looked into the actual
topic deeply
yeah i have actually and most people go
to leviticus 19
where it talks about um
marking your body or cutting your body
yeah in the new king james translation
it actually says
you shall not make any cuttings in your
flesh for the dead nor tattoo any marks
on you i am the lord
sounds pretty straightforward yeah yeah
they go there but then you know the
argument would be well you gotta you
have to read the whole thing and you got
to do exactly what it says right like
the not eating pork and
also there's the the beard uh not
cutting your beard over corners right
right and so
so i studied this deeply and what i
found um
there's a principle
in the bible if you go to mark five
if you go to i mean not
let's go to let's go to proverbs 6 first
in proverbs 6 it says
um these
six things dot the lord hate yea seven
are an abomination unto him and the very
first thing is a proud look
and that's that's pretty much you know
what i was getting it for because i want
to look cool yeah you know and with that
though you can also apply if i only wear
nike
you know if i'm if i'm all about fendi
and gucci you know it's like
you can have that
dead it's maybe not on my skin but you
got the pride like look i got this fendi
built on you know or whatever or your
car or your job
or your house or whatever yeah yeah
so it's all based on principle now if
you go to mark five now i i've never
connected this to tattoos before but
when i really searched about because i
wanted to get more tattoos
and a lot of guys
this was
maybe five years ago okay five years ago
and so mark five this was when um
jesus and the disciples went into
i think the gadarenes
and it says in verse starting from verse
one it says and they came over onto the
other side of the sea
into the country of the gadarenes and
when he was come out of the ship
immediately there met him out of the
tombs a man with an unclean spirit so
this was a demon-possessed man right
and then it says who had his dwelling
among the tombs and no man could bind
him no not with chains because that he
had been often bound with fetters and
chains and the chains had been plucked
asunder by him and fetters broke broken
in pieces neither could any man tame him
now watch what it says and and always
night and day he was in the mountains
and in the tombs crying and cutting
himself with stones
so he was cutting himself now
tattoos are
needles puncturing your skin but it's
the same principle yeah it's not it's
not cutting yourself but it's self-harm
you see what i mean i mean
what's the difference in a cut and a
prick that goes all the way across your
body i mean
in the tattoo shops they have
scarification as well if you want a
certain design you can get branding you
can get scarification and a lot of the
traditional tattoos like if you're in
africa or something
they will they'll take a knife they'll
cut it and they'll shove berries and
their skin and the open wound and that's
how they do the tattoo so that's the
cutting but what you just read reminds
me of also when elijah elijah
was gonna bring fire down from heaven
and first the pagans were
trying to get bail i think to bring down
themselves yeah and they're they're
trying to do anything they can to get
their god to listen and they start
cutting themselves and it's like that's
that's pagan
so it's when you when you look at where
this stuff originates we are kind of
born into this
generation where it's so common i mean
even when i was a kid it wasn't that
common like maybe your uncle had
something on his arm or something an
anchor or something
but like now it's like
dude rappers have face tattoos like
everywhere and it's like
it's getting insane and so it's becoming
so acceptable and and normalized that we
don't even think of it as as being
controversial at all or taboo and yet
where did this stuff come from
i think originally it probably did come
out of
paganism and out of false worship
i don't think the apostles were getting
tattoos you know but there was people
around them that clearly were because
even leviticus old testament that's
another good point
leviticus is a very old book people are
getting tattoos that far back this is
nothing like new and cool and hip and we
just made it up so it can't be a sin
right it's listed in the bible so so
it's i'm imagining like these cultures
that would make these little incisions
and cut and then they would scar up and
then you have these designs on you maybe
like samoan or something like that too
you know um is that kind of what you
guys are envisioning with him cutting
himself it wasn't just to like inflict
harm he's actually decorating his body
kind of a thing
with this guy
yeah with the goddess demon possessed i
don't think i don't know if he was
decorating his body
but the principle is still there you
know he's cutting yourself self-harm
yeah it's just like i've said it many
times like satan has a tackle box
everybody oh you don't like cutting
yourself what about tattoos yeah i look
cool so to to make it clear for the
audience
where where is the harm coming in what
it what are the is there any medical
evidence that points to this is not good
for you or is it just the fact that you
punctured your skin
multiple times over as the needle goes
in and out
well i mean definitely there's some
medical risk i mean if it's not clean
and if you're allergic to the ink i saw
somebody who every tattoo they had that
had red in it was a constant wound
because they said there's actually metal
in the red and they're allergic to it
um but i think even if you're somebody
who's like me i never had any issues
with tattoos i still don't think i
should do it not because of some kind of
medical issue but there was a verse that
somebody brought up to you
about our bodies being the temple of god
and i've actually seen like a t-shirt
that says your body is the temple so
decorate it or something you know and i
just think that's like
not not the way to do it i don't i think
that's a twisting of concept you can
decorate it the way that god would want
you to decorate it not you know not the
way that we think we we should decorate
it right that's what i mean
i also think in a subtle way it's really
just trying to take something that i
don't know you could correct me if i'm
wrong but like taking something that's
beautiful that god designed you know the
human body is really a a work of art
it's amazing and saying it's not good
enough i'm going to improve upon it and
put my own spin on it and stuff and you
know instead of like you know god being
the life giver it's like we got now
skulls and i mean i think that this
image even that you have on here is very
interesting you've got jesus and then
you've got like all these like death
skull you know grim reaper type people
over that like
yeah yeah it's just it's it's a sad
state of affair that we we feel like we
have to mar god's beautiful creation
yeah it's like
it's it's our human mentality we're
we're not
godly minded naturally we're sinful and
imagine god's telling moses you know
build the temple just like this and then
one of those people
you know one of the israelites was like
a tagger i was like oh dude
yeah and they're like on the side of
that thing and they're thinking dude
that looks awesome and moses is just
like i can't believe you just defiled
what god told me to build exactly and
like you're talking about
the
body
is a masterpiece it's a good point when
was it ezekiel or isaiah that saw the
sanctuary and there was like markings
all inside of it which one had the
vision
it was ezekiel right
um you know god gave him a peek through
the through the hole and and it was like
all just like marked up with stuff yeah
so there's a bunch of images hanging on
the wall yeah yeah you could do that and
kind of makes me think of
my room as a teenager when i used to
have like marilyn manson posters and
everything all over my wall like
literally idols
i didn't think of them that way well i
guess i did i mean he was my idol it was
metal music was like you said rap got
you into the tattoos it was that music
lifestyle for me music wasn't just
something i listened to it was a
lifestyle so when i listen to gothic
music yeah i want to get a pentagram
tattoo in my hand
um and i had those idols all over my
walls and i think you know just like
what ezekiel saw
we it's it's not some kind of like old
what do they call it arbitrary or like
archaic concept that we don't
have in our world today it's just
different it just looks different
how about the new testament like okay we
know the old testament but we we have a
lot of people that pay attention to our
channel and they're like well if you
just follow what the old testament says
you have to do everything like you
mentioned before is there any new
testament evidence for
you know maybe not marking up your body
well the the mark 5 verse yeah i guess
that's it that's just right and then
also
you know your body is the temple yeah to
take care of it people bring this up to
me you know people who
i guess justify tattoos
they bring up i think it's in revelation
um
oh i'd like to see it versus the
justified tattoo yeah actually that's
that's a really good point
no i mean just like there's people that
actually have things that they think
support the idea of getting
so so this is what they bring up in
revelation 19 where um
it talks about jesus christ having a
name on his thigh
yeah
he's also got it on his forehead too
yeah yeah yeah so this is interesting
yeah they bring that up and then also
um you know they bring up the the fact
that the 144 000 have the father's name
on the forehead you know but we we know
like if you if you study deeply a name
in the bible if you go to um for i think
it's for first samuel second first
samuel 25 and verse 25 it says as his
name is so is he yeah so a name in the
bible is symbolic for your character
that's right and if you look at the
original greek or hebrew you'll see that
kind of in the definition of it yeah
there actually is a guy found on youtube
that has
the hebrew yahweh on his forehead
tattooed and he's
he's doing his thing on youtube doing
some uh
preaching and stuff
that's that's an interesting view
because if you think about it from that
standpoint then
you know how do you how do you take the
view that a lot of people have like oh
you know the mark is going to be like
this thing tattooed into your hand or
your forehead it's like well
that doesn't justify getting it
so you can't exactly apply that
principle that's because i think it's
counterfeit of the good tattoo you know
it's got it it's good and bad imagine
going into heaven and it's like the
first thing that you have to do is like
sit in the tattoo
know like
which that's another good point too
we're we're trying to live
prepared for heaven
and
one of the first things it says is
you're going to put on a new body
put on immortality and corruptable you
know and why i think of that i don't
think of a body that's covered like this
an incorruptible tattooed body
so i guess where i was going to go with
some of this is is
the bible's full of imagery right and so
if you look at revelation you have two
women one is pure she basically has a
white robe that's it the other one is
dressed to the nines you know decked out
jewelry you know this and that it's like
she's putting on extra and god's like no
no the one over here that has simply
nothing but my robe
that's what you need
you go back to the beginning you have
the garden right
adam and eve they send what do they
start doing oh we need to cover
ourselves right whatever we think that
it is that we need to cover ourselves
with
we're a degraded human race like we've
been just destroying everything since
you know sin was instituted
we need to go back to the simplicity of
what does god want us to have what does
he want to clothe us with what you know
because
here's satan you know you read about him
in ezekiel and isaiah and it's like yeah
he met every precious jewel was his
covering but god chose that for him you
know he didn't choose that for us
there's actually some verses in genesis
that talk about um in the beginning when
it's describing the earth that there was
the onyx here and the different stones
that were on the ground right and so the
logic there is when god created the
world there was precious stones laying
on the on the surface of the ground
because in genesis it says that he sunk
those things below the earth because
man's vain hearts were making those
things you know idols and so what was
the logic that god was doing by bending
down and creating you out of dirt and
mud if there's stones laying around and
god's clearly not against jewelry so to
say meaning like
what you brought up with is satan you
know he put those jewels on satan it
says that there's those things were set
in him that means god designed that to
be in them but he didn't choose to do
that with us i think the illustration
there is
look at how satan fell because of the
brightness of his being right it was the
pride of his outside so god was saying
well let me show you what's really
important it's not your outside it's
your inside so i think that's why it's
really important too for us not to do
things that that bolster up the pride of
our outside
instead spend that time and energy
bolstering up the valuable things of
your character yeah and of course when
jesus said it came you know isaiah it's
like you know there was no beauty but we
should behold him it came simple yeah
you know yeah humble yeah it was his
character was his character
and really
all outward things are going to fade
whether it's your physical beauty or the
clothing you wear it's all going to
deteriorate it's all going to wrinkle
the one thing that lasts is your
character and when you're really like
getting to know somebody you can meet
the most beautiful person in the world
and they become ugly because their
character is
bitter and and negative
but you meet somebody that you might not
really consider that attractive and you
find they have a beautiful personality
they're friendly they're caring they
have a servant-like attitude and that
person becomes attractive
because that inward attractiveness is
coming out so there's young people out
there and they're like man i want to get
a tattoo this is a thing it's cool you
know
and
i can see like in the heat of that
moment when you're young you're not
thinking long term at all you know let's
say you want to go get a bulldog on your
arm you know 70 years that bulldog
becomes a sharpay
so
what are some things that you guys have
noticed in your lives or as you reflect
back on the years that you're like i can
see why this wasn't a good idea
long term
i used to think
when people always say are you not going
to want that when you're older you know
i'm like when i'm older i'm really ugly
and wrinkled anyway so why do i care if
i got a tattoo but
i do regret these things i i had so many
people tell me oh don't get that you
regret it i regret all mine and i'm like
well i'm not gonna get something i
regret and and to me
i was like
this thing that i'm getting i'm all
about it i'm never gonna change and i
look at him like i don't even like the
same bands i used to listen to even like
before i became a christian i'm like oh
that band sold out they only sound good
and it's like i'm glad i didn't get a
corn tattoo or whatever because that
used to be like my favorite band and
then they started sounding weak
and uh so you just never know
and yeah i don't think
like you said we don't think long term
enough about it and i i regret all of
them i
i can't wait for my new body to be pure
yeah me too i regret all of my tattoos i
wish i could just
you know remove
all my tattoos but it just
takes a lot of money to just to remove
all these things so to answer that
question why don't you get your tattoos
removed i've had people ask me that like
you need to get that thing covered up or
tattooed yeah or removed i'm like okay
so if
what we saw
well here's the first question is
getting a tattoo of sin
yeah let's let's let's hear your guys's
thoughts on this i'm not gonna answer
that because i
i have no experience in this area
well
okay i would say that being
proud and boastful
clearly that's a sin
clearly
um
so if the tattoos make you proud and
boastful which it did for me
you know for for you know many years
um i would show these things off and so
yeah that's i think it would lead to
that you know it would lead to sin can i
throw a kind of a monkey wrench into it
what about a person that has maybe a
child that dies
and is like i i've heard from parents
there's no pain no pain like having a
child die like your parent can die
your spouse can die
totally different ball game when your
child dies
and the fear that the parent goes
through is i will forget that person
in that circum circumstance i mean
i was just about to say the same thing i
was like there's gonna be plenty of
people who say i didn't get this because
it makes me look cool it's hidden it's
my grandmother's name or something
but then you gotta look at the verse we
read
ye shall not make any cuttings which
tattoos
in your flesh for the dead
nor print any marks upon you i am the
lord to me it's just so clear cut if if
any other scripture in the bible said
you shall not fornicate i am the lord
i'm not going to say well maybe he
didn't mean that yeah and not under that
circumstance i'm on an island and there
was only one girl you know yeah like
yeah we're always trying to find an
excuse for sin and you have to take a
look at the bible and say
thus sayeth the word of god i must order
my life after that excellent verse and
there was a verse that keith brought up
about
uh him that knowed to do good i think
it's in james i don't remember 100 but
to him that knows to do good and does
not do it to him it is sin
now
we're talking about tattoos but that
verse has a broad application i mean
there's a ton of things that fall in our
lives
under that category like if we know to
do good and we're not doing it or we're
resistant to the leading of the holy
spirit or that conviction that god is
bringing to our mind
you know woe to us
for whatever that is and so
i think the main thrust is like not like
okay you got a tattoo you're a sinner
you're condemned you can never be saved
you know
that's not the attitude at all it's more
like is this in god's order is it part
of his plan for us
and
you know i think biblically we could say
no it's not but if you got one
and that was your life that was your
past now you're a different creation
you're a new creation you're a new
person
then it's not upon us
to pass judgment on that person you know
and the flip side of that verse would be
to do something and not know it is sin
yeah not really sin i mean is actually
acts new testament x says that god winks
at those stands coming in ignorance i
think
if you're truly an ignorance you had no
idea and you're like oh i'm a christian
i want to get a cross yeah and then you
die the next day god's not going to hold
you accountable for yeah he's going to
be like you know so here's the here that
is here's the clarify yeah exactly
here's the clarifier it's like there are
things we can be ignorant of
there's still sin
we may not understand that it's sin but
it's still sin and so that's why i'm
like want to be clear that yeah just
because you don't understand it
you can't look at it like well it's not
sin because i didn't know yeah
we ultimately don't know how god's gonna
judge that's why he's the righteous
judge when we get to heaven every tongue
will profess to say god you made the
right choice like this person's not here
because because he didn't want to be and
you made the judgment call on that thing
so i think that god will wink in our in
our times of ignorance you know there's
a lot of variables here that that are
impossible for us to look at and say
well you did that and you didn't know so
you're not going to make it yeah like
there's the
drug addict you know gangbanger who
comes to christ and he dies a year after
coming to christ and and during that
time he got some tattoos biblical
tattoos and he was seeking but he never
came to this verse he never got to see
this verse like wow tattoos are sin and
he dies we're all going to be at the
judgment and jesus is going to say come
on in and we're going to be like him he
didn't know can i tell you something
that i appreciate about having you
gentlemen involved in ministries and
things for me to observe
something that i know god has rescued
you out of a life to me that's what it
speaks at when i see you i that's my
first thought was like wow there's no
depths of dark holes that we as humans
can climb into but praise god that he
pulls people out of that and here you
are both working in beautiful ministries
uh i mean tilla you you've had a a
really amazing youtube channel that has
taught and and and you know you've got a
lot of followers that are learning
incredible amounts from your ministry i
mean school of profits um if you guys
haven't checked out school of profits
please do so check this guy out because
i hear all the time i i go around and
and speak in different churches and
people always mention your ministry
they're always like i watch you guys i
watch school of prophets
and so you know praise god that he
doesn't say you know what taylor you've
got some tattoos on you and so you need
to clean up before you come work for me
to me
seeing you guys work in ministry is like
praise god he's not waiting for you to
all of a sudden have this perfect
package
he's using you as you are right now
and i've heard multiple stories from
other people and i and i think even
mikey too
and you've probably had this experience
there are some people they look at
you're like man you got tattoos i'm
discounting there are other people are
like
man you got tattoos i can't believe
somebody like me is like that i got
tattoos i'm gonna listen to that guy
right yeah whereas somebody who's
totally clean cut suit tied dressed to
the nines whole bit
they're not going to give them the time
of day yeah exactly you kind of brought
that up
on one of the shows i was watching that
you did
it's like that's not a justification to
say well i'm a pastor i'll get a tattoo
so i can connect with them but it shows
how god can use everybody differently
like god can use us in a different way
than he can use them he's been into
martial arts i cannot
connect with somebody like that i don't
know anything about it and people would
know immediately that i don't know what
i'm talking about you know about
hollywood you know
god can use each of our past our
testimonies
they overcame by the blood of the lamb
and the word of their testimonies i
think there's a lot in that
and
yeah i think that we're all part of the
body of christ
um
that talks about us being like
like a body you know
a body needs ears and eyes and noses and
mouths and the mouth isn't saying i wish
i could hear you know it all makes one
functioning thing i think that's why god
used um the disciples that he did
i think you'd have connected with one of
them yeah i mean the straight-up heart
up fisherman that's like you know ready
to go out and fist fight you if you you
know do whatever like he he he literally
said i bet you i and i just i don't have
nothing to substantiate this on but i
bet you each one of those represented a
certain type of personality or class or
something that that people would
identify with fisherman tax collector
uh paul was like killing christians
persecutor you think about the different
classes that they're in too you know and
and
the people that jesus was calling like
the rich young ruler yeah i mean he was
calling him first but you can reach a
demographic that the rest of these guys
can't reach you know you're rubbing
elbows in high society
i need you you know nicodemus same way i
need you in that realm to reach those
people yeah
yeah it's interesting too because a
friend of mine when he first started
watching my video that was the first
thing that he watched was the tattoo
thing
and he's like i'm not watching this but
then when he watched the whole thing
he's like man i have to you know i have
to admit he he made some good points you
know
so yeah i use it now you know for a
testimony than anything yeah i mean yeah
man
well i think this was a you know a
beneficial show because like we said we
don't want people to be in ignorance we
don't want people sinning unknowingly
and we do have a responsibility as
christians to dig in this word and find
out what what how am i supposed to live
what to do what not to do
and so if you guys had any questions
about tattoos i hope this answered some
questions maybe it brought up more
questions if it brought up any other
questions put them down in the comments
we'll get back to you
but uh if if you agree with it give us a
thumbs up if you think that this would
benefit some friend don't forget to
share it and subscribe to this channel
if you're new and don't forget to check
out school for prophets he actually has
a really cool video called from
babylon to america and also from america
to babylon
really amazing documentaries that have
millions of views 10 plus millions of
views now so check that out it's a it's
a lot about
uh bible prophecy and where all this is
going who's the beast what is the mark
all those things and it's really well
done it's got really cool animations and
stuff so we will see you guys next week
on led live
visit our brothers at school for
prophets.tv and watch from babylon to
america which has over 5 million views
on youtube alone and follow it up with
america 2 babylon check the description
below for links to this and more
[Music]
foreign